For many beer aficionados “tastes like warm
piss” is perhaps the most withering insult
one can hurl in the general direction of a
given beer.
While you wouldn’t begrudge a member of
the public making such a claim about a particular
beer, you’d think brewers themselves would
have a little more decorum.
Something nobody apparently told a certain
Heineken distributor in the 1980s when they
were able to convince the general public that
Corona literally contained human urine.
The origins of this sordid tale of corporate
shenanigans can be traced back to 1979 and
the American debut of Corona.
Described officially as a “pale lager”
the urine coloured Mexican-beer is the flagship
product of Mexican brewer Grupo Modelo and
has a respectable share of the beer market
in most countries it is sold.
Upon its debut in America the beer was a hit,
quickly becoming one of the most well-known
and in-demand imported beers in the entire
country.
In particular, Corona was noted as being especially
popular with “young urban professionals”
drawn to the “surfer aesthetic” the company
had cultivated in its advertising.
According to industry experts, by 1986 Corona
had captured around half a percent of the
entire American beer market.
This may not sound like a lot, but it represented
sales to the tune of 13 million cases of beer
annually, which after adjusting for inflation
for the cost of each case, would be in today’s
dollars well over $300 million in gross revenue.
These sales numbers also made the zesty Mexican
lager the second most popular imported beer
in the entire United States behind Dutch beer,
Heineken.
This all brings us to 1986, when Corona executives
noticed that sales of the beer had begun to
stall across the United States for no readily
apparent reason.
In fact, in some regions sales dropped by
as much as 80% while, oddly, in others nothing
much changed at all in the figures.
Confused Corona reached out to their suppliers
in regions of the U.S. where sales were stalling
and found that, not only was the beer not
selling as well when it was stocked, some
stores had actually stopped stocking it entirely.
Corona then did some sleuthing and discovered
that there was a frankly bizarre rumor being
spread in bars across the United States that
Mexican workers at the main Corona brewery
frequently urinated in the vats used to ferment
the beer.
While this might seem farfetched, it is noteworthy
that the act of peeing in beer to make for
a more robust flavor was actually historically
a thing, with the practice called leinting.
In fact, the 1742 London and Country Brewer
lamented this, stating, “…putting chamberly,
or human urine, into… pale or amber towpenny
malt drink… [is] nasty, horrid, and a detestable
piece of cunning and knavery…”
Nevertheless, there are many references to
such happening from this era, as well as many
more references of rumors to such, whether
true or not in many cases isn’t clear.
But the point is, people have been accusing
beer makers of adding urine to their brew
seemingly as long as humans have been making
beer.
Thus, it’s no surprise that at some point
someone got the bright idea to insinuate that
Corona, a pale yellow beer sold in clear bottles,
also contained urine.
And it’s further perhaps not surprising
that people actually believed it given attitudes
at the time towards Mexican manufacturing
of just about anything.
This all left Corona in the rather bizarre
predicament of needing to get the word out
that they did not actually allow anyone to
pee in their beer, spending about $500,000
(about $1.1 million today) on ads informing
the public of this, while executives appeared
on dozens of talk shows to reiterate the same
point.
Not without risk, the company was well aware
that by specifically denying that they put
urine in their beer, this may actually have
resulted in the rumor just getting spread
even further.
Nevertheless, as one Corona distributor executive,
Michael Mazzoni, noted, “We recognize there’s
an element of risk in what we’ve done, but
we thought it was necessary to have the truth
out there.”
While they were doing this, a Chicago-based
distributor of the beer, Barton Beers Ltd,
who the aforementioned Michael Mazzoni worked
for, decided to play detective and see if
they could find out where the rumors had begun.
They eventually traced it back to Reno, Nevada
as the jumping off point.
And when investigating further, found that
it appeared that employees of a rival distributor
called Luce & Sons Inc, who primarily imported
the beer Heineken, were the ones who initially
spread the idea.
Luce & Sons quickly found themselves staring
down a rather sizable lawsuit, but ultimately
paid a settlement out of court and were made
to give a public statement saying that Corona
wasn’t actually filled with piss.